vous êtes
je
suis trouvé un
je veux savoir la vérité
pour vraiment la comprendre il faut en
faire l'expérience directe
faut
la
un transport par avion n'est plus
possible je croyais que la mission était
urgente
la preuve de sa mort était fausse
il m'enait
le beau cauchemar ou vieux
est-ce que c'est tiré une balle dans son
bunker à Berlin il y a des hommes de la
where Wolf qui cherchent le corps il y a
personne ici personne ne surveille on se
fout de nos affaires mieux vaut
continuer jusqu'à
la where Wolf
il brûle du lichen et des champignons
ça provoque des visions
on le trouvera
eux ils mourront
on devrait partir
où est le Führer
alors pourquoi le cacher
Staline doit avoir le corps
et si tu mourrais en essayant de
protéger le secret c'est fini
il y a un loup à la porte
est-ce que reculer devant le sacrifice
total est un déshonneur les campagnes
batailles victorieuses n'existent plus
pas dans cette guerre non
l'histoire n'est pas écrite par les
vainqueurs et les perpétuer par ceux qui
lui ont survécu